And what sort of things do you think
in your personality, or maybe in your
co-founder's personalities, made you
guys so successful at the beginning?
>> When I look back at that,
I really think it was, I mean it was,
first of all it was a lot of hard work.
It was a lot of luck, frankly.
I think we worked a lot
on our communication.
But more than anything else, it was
hustle, and it was the willingness and
the ability to get back
up each time we stumble.
Every entrepreneur goes through
some great highs, hopefully,
and some real low lows and when
you're working, whether it's alone or
with somebody else,
the ones who are successful are the ones
who are able to stand up after
falling over and dust themselves off.
And learn what they needed to from it.
I think what I just talked
about was an example of that.
>> Yeah.
>> Where you could see actually when you
looked back at our progress, how we
were learning that lesson the hard way.
Probably took us way to long,
but we learned it.
>> And you got there.
>> And we got there.
>> So what sorts of skills do you
think are really important for
entrepreneur to have at the outset?
>> I'm going to just pick two things.
The first one is resilience,
just being able to bounce back after
something doesn't go your way.
You have to get really comfortable
hearing the word no and as a small
company that nobody knows about
you're going to hear it an awful lot.
And the second one is I think the
willingness to step outside of whatever
room it is that you're in.
And maybe this is motivated
by the fact that I
come at this from an engineering
perspective where the easy part and
the fun part is writing code,
is building something.
But that was never useful to do
that until I had built a real
understanding of what
the customer wanted.
And that doesn't happen until
you get outside of your room and
start talking to people.
And so, I think,
developing those two skills is more
important than anything else,
at the outset.
>> So, what's one thing that you wish
you would have known before getting
started with Optimizely?
>> You know, when we started
our entrepreneurial journey,
we started actually working on
something completely different.
And we built an education platform for
young kids called Carrot Sticks.
Had nothing to do with what
we ended up working on.
I think when I look back at
that time what strikes me is
how much time we spent working on things
that didn't actually end up mattering.
We spent a lot of time building
things that nobody cared about
because we didn't spend enough time
getting to know our customers.
And we struggled for a year,
frankly, without salaries,
and that was a pretty difficult time and
I think during that year we had to
really erase what we thought we
knew about starting companies and
really learn how to probe and
understand the customers that we were.
trying to serve.
And you can see that in our first
company, Carrot Sticks, it took us about
six months before we earned
a dollar doing what we were doing.
With our second company, which I won't
even go into, it took about a month and
a half, so
you can see our learning scale shrunk.
And then with Optimizely we
actually were able to earn money
on day one before we'd written any code.
And I think that's the signal for, first
of all, the fact that we'd gotten better
at understanding our customers, but also
for how skeptical we'd gotten of our own
ideas, and that we weren't even willing
to work on something unless we were able
to prove that it was something
people wanted enough to pay for.